[Music]
for our series pushing the limits we're
introducing you
to one of the most physically demanding
olympic sports and
a young athlete hoping to make history
this summer in tokyo
seventeen-year-old evy leibfarth is
forging ahead
with her rigorous training in canoe
slalom
despite uncertainty over that whether
the summer games will be canceled
due to covid concerns maria villarreal
recently spent the day with a young
american
at the u.s national white water center
near charlotte north carolina
before she heads to japan next month
at just 17 years old emmy leibarth is
forging
a new path to the olympics
since the 1970s canoe slalom has been a
summer games sport
in which only men could compete until
now
here's how it works athletes navigate a
whitewater course passing through a
combination of upstream and downstream
gates
leibfarth will be the first woman ever
to compete for the u.s
in this category people will come after
you but you are
the first it's so fun to be a part of
something
when it's going to be in the games for
the first time so i'm not worried about
the pressure of it
and while she may not feel the pressure
of competing at this level
she does recognize the significance of
her presence
this year it is completely gender equal
two women two men
you're 17 years old and you're talking
about gender equality
how do we get to this point i remember
being 12 years old and like pestering
all like the older athletes about like
why are there more men in this
leiparth's love for the sport came well
before she started competing on an
international level at age
12. just out of diapers abby was
introduced to kayaking by her dad
who was also a professional athlete she
would sit in my lap and we'd go down
very easy rivers
and she would just smile and laugh and
then she got her own little kayak and
just took one right is that the pink one
the little pink one yes and it was so
small it would actually fit in the front
seat of our car
we'll go down down down and then after
the bridge there's a dive on the right
leli farth isn't just evie's dad once
you're warmed up a little bit try to get
just a little bit lactic okay
he's also her coach part of your job it
is to push the athlete a little bit but
this is your daughter also you know my
goal as a coach first and foremost was
to make sure that evie was having fun in
the sport
is there a healthy competition between
the two of y'all
i mean there's again i'm hearing a
little bit of that now i bet i could
take you out now
when covet hit last year and the olympic
games were postponed
the family moved across the state to
help keep her on track
it kind of allowed us to take a step
back and really focus on some of like
the really important parts of my
training it didn't really take the
window to sales it kind of did the
opposite
when she was competing in 2015 she was
competing against girls that were in
their 20s and 30s who were just
physically stronger than she was so this
gave us a chance to hit the gym to work
with the trainer a little bit more
and really build on things that take a
longer amount of time to develop
so a lot of people tell me that
hummingbird strokes
a lot of people when they paddle forward
um it's kind of more of a slow strong
stroke
i do the opposite that i have like
really fast ropes that no one else has
and it works really well for me evie is
looking forward to competing in tokyo
but her overall goal is to win big on
her home turf in 2028
when the games come back to los angeles
you know there's there's a lot of young
girls out there that watch and will say
wow this guy could be her how important
is it for you
to know that you could be inspiring the
next the next generation
so important that's such a big goal of
mine is to get more girls into sport and
you know of course into my sport but
really like getting them outdoors and
young girls can do whatever they set
their minds to
like paddling into history one
hummingbird stroke at a time
for cbs this morning medea via charlotte
north carolina
that's amazing really incredible i'm
looking forward to kayaking this summer
on the quiet cape cod bay just a couple
paddles at a time
that's a fun sport to watch yeah it is
very cool right now the olympics are
still on i hope for the athletes
for the athletes look at the numbers
it's a little dicey a little dicey a
little dicey you look at how much work
she's put in you really hope it goes
ahead
go evie you go yeah not my kind of
kayaking i like to put a drink there
right in the front i think
on those rapids they do a wonderful job
looking forward to watching that as well